this is perhaps the biggest foreign
policy error by a sitting prime minister
in the modern era of politics it's a
bizarre ties with the with the trading
block that was originally created to
enable peace in Europe and then became
an economic instrument to improve trade
ties between us germany and france and
the like and and the threat to that the
less trade retribution from our European
neighbors the risk there's as David
Cameron himself warned of recession in
the UK markets are taking a battery not
just in the UK but around the world the
Sterling has plunged stocks from Asia to
London and likely the US have a tumbled
everyone's going to accept a lot of
uncertainty in how we met in our
European and negotiations whether they
will allow us to have to maintain some
ties and what time trade deal will have
uncertainty over the future of central
bank policy and uncertainty two on two
fronts both the rise of populist
movements that we're seeing with Donald
Trump in the u.s. because this have
implications for November it's going to
set up food fights for the ultimately
the the best job in British politics a
leader of a g7 nation is is at stake and
you're going to see a lot of elbow
elbows out trying to achieve that you
have to go back to the war and to the
suez crisis and events like that to
really get a scale of what what's
happened to David Cameron he he called a
referendum thinking it would solve the
problems of a Conservative Party it's
only aggravated divisions within the
party and it's ultimately cost him his
job